you've written about the history of Life
on Mars like you said you've kind of
exploring that by looking at the Lakes
here
um do you think there's been Life on
Mars do you think there is life on Mars
right so when you're looking at the
environment of Mars early on it's fairly
similar to that of early Earth never was
exactly the same because Mars was always
farther from the Sun uh than the earth
right so it was always a little cooler
but you have to imagine maybe the Arctic
during the summer that would be early
Mars with a lot going on for it in terms
of environment very favorable to even
Life as we know it so
we don't know how fast life
happen on Earth they are signs right now
showing that it might have actually
originated only 200 million years after
the crust cooled down yeah uh this still
has to be verified but that that's the
closest and these are indirect evidence
like
carbon left by the activity of life not
life itself and there is a Twist in the
story for Mars is that it seems that
Mars came together as a planet faster
than the earth and had water earlier
than the earth
so it may be that Mars was habitable and
might have seen
the beginning of Life
earlier than the Earth
so all of this is speculation obviously
we haven't found any evidence or solid
evidence yet I would say unambiguous
evidence but unambiguous evidence of
life is going to be something uh
interesting to prove because we don't
know what life is remember so I always
joke that the only way we would know
that there is life on Mars if there was
a rabbit jumping in front of the of the
Rover but we might be you know Gathering
we have what we call a ladder of Life
detection which is that you have a
series of uh rungs that you know you
need to go through
that actually are not proving you that
you've discovered life but are making
um the possibility that what you
discovered was made only by the
environment more and more and probable
so we are trying to prove the contrary
right so this is what we have right now
and as far as I'm concerned
continuing all the unknowns we have I
think there was as much chance that life
originated on Mars that they did on
Earth and
um if it was at the surface then it got
in trouble after 5 million 100 million
years because of The Disappearance of
the magnetosphere the loss of the
magnetosphere and the atmosphere but as
we know you know life doesn't only
stay in one place as soon as it's out
there it's going to adapt it's going to
give itself more chance
to survive and that to me means that if
life appeared I would say
it's still there and probably on the
ground where it can be you know in an
environment that's more stable so I
don't know how stability is good or not
it might not be so good but they might
be in a different type of metabolism
through dormancy you know waiting for
different climate cycles and there is
the fact that Mars changes but it's
faster
than the earth and climate changes are a
lot stronger in magnitude so there might
be a place on Mars we know that there is
a place on Mars deeper in the subsurface
where temperature and pressure are good
for liquid water to stay there so these
would be good places for a stable
habitat over time no matter what happens
at the surface
but if uh life is also caught
between that deep Zone and the surface
there is an active layer there is a lot
of ice in the subsurface of Mars and
when the climate changes when the
obliquity goes beyond 30 degrees then at
that point you will have some activation
of that zone you have falling of the
eyes so all this region is reactivated
and maybe that's a way where you have
Pathways for life to move from the deep
Zone to closer to the surface this is
why I am one of those scientists who
thinks that life might not be so far
from the surface than we think
so we don't have to dig very far to find
it we probably won't and the reason I'm
not so amazing I I'm thinking of that
just because of this experience as well
of extreme environments you know you
have to sit and look and listen
basically the story of my life if I want
to understand where microbes are located
on Mars I have to become the microbe
right this is the thought experiment and
if I want to understand where ET is yeah
then I have to become ET so it's a big
stretch but in extreme environment you
sit in the desert for a while and you
just you know try to understand
where the wind's coming from where the
humidity when it's showing up and then
you start to understand the patterns of
those things what are the useful signals
that you need for survival you need to
know where water is where the source of
energy is going to be uh drawn from you
need to find shelters and shelters don't
mean that for instance you can have a
water column of a lake or a river or
whatnot or the ocean it can be also a
very thin layer of dust or it can be a
translucent Rock
and you see what we call endless these
are the same cyanobacteria but the
different version of them they live
inside the Rocks inside those crystals
because they have the best of Life they
are into translucent crystals so that
they receive the light from the sun they
can do the photosynthesis
but there is enough of that Crystal so
that the nasty UV is being stopped
and they are in their little house
and um when you are looking at the
temperature within those rocks they tend
to make it toastier than the outside
temperature so there is a lot of thing
going on
um so what I'm saying for Mars is that
yeah right now you don't have an
atmosphere very much 160 times thinner
than the earth six millibar is really
not much but it's there
um but you still have a lot of UV the
short UV like the nasty one UVA UVB UVC
that can really mess up your DNA uh and
and destroy it Beyond repair
but as soon as you have a little alcove
into a rock or a cliff
you know
I'd be looking at those places but you
have to understand Mars or any other
planet for that matter at the level that
matters for the microbe
and is so then maybe one with the
microbe one with the microbes which
means that we have lots of orbital data
which is good to understand habitability
at the planet level or at the regional
level
but we have very little data right now
that is very useful to understand
habitability
uh at the scale that matters for the
microbes at this point in time so we
need to uh to do a better job with that
my ideas uh is to you know have arrays
of environmental situation that could
have a lot of benefits one would be to
give us that Vision at for the microbes
that would be good for us through
biology
and second a collection of stations on
Mars on Mars yeah yeah that give us a
good map yeah high resolution we can do
that regionally and on top of that so
that's good for us through biology for
the search for Life on Mars that's good
about how to learn where microbes could
be that can be a problem for
contamination both ways so that's good
for planetary protection and since those
stations would have communication
capabilities on them that excellent for
human exploration because now not only
you have weather stations all over the
place that can tell your astronauts you
know learn the pattern when it's a good
time to go out or not go out and also
house and communicate uh when they they
go and do sorties so there are a number
of things we can do that can tell you
lots of information